be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books what's going on
guys this is Rob and welcome to another
episode of the rundown where I just
present you guys with a story and I'm
like here is a thing that was cool and I
really enjoyed it and you guys should
check it out too and in this video after
doing a poll on Twitter which you guys
can find me there at comics explained I
asked people what video should we do
should we do like Thor vs. Galactus or
should we do the story about how the
Joker wanted a copyright fish
I think the Joker copyrighting fish is a
better story but the people had spoken
and they were like we want to see Thor
vs. Galactus so this is Thor vs.
Galactus now this story has its roots at
the beginning of Jason Aaron's run and
this is important because for like 20
years Thor was like the most irrelevant
character ever he didn't really matter
he had his hammer and it was cool but
his stories were just kind of dumb
because it was like the Superman effect
like how can you write a good story with
a character that's basically
undefeatable and so what ended up
happening is in 2011 Marvel launched
Marvel now which was in response to DC's
reboot of the new 52 among it was like
holy cow
DC's crushing us in sales we need to do
what we did with Secret Wars and lie to
everybody and issue new number ones
calling it a reboot and so they gave us
new number ones and Jason Aaron and Asad
Rubik took over the the Thor series so
what they did is Jason Aaron launched a
story called the god butcher and the god
butcher was based on a character named
gore now why it is a Jason Aaron thought
that Thor and Gore needed to have such
similar names that is a question I do
not have the answer to but the fact
remains that Gore was basically like
every angsty teenage boy ever he was
like oh man things are going my way so
I'm just going to throw a big temper
tantrum and complain about it on the
internet the difference is that instead
of complaining on the Internet Gore
wreaked havoc across the universe and
killed all the gods and he did this by
basically capturing a weapon that was
called the necro sword and the necro
sword had these magical properties that
we call that a plot device in the realm
of comics and he used it to kill gods
who normally would have been unkillable
and so this story took place over the
course of three separate time periods it
took place during the first time that
Thor encountered Gore way back in the
day and like 800 BC and then it took
place in the present and then it took
place in the future and the future is
what we care about now with regards to
these three different timelines
at the end of the story they all met up
together and they were all like okay
this guy Gor is being kind of a dick and
he's killing gods we should kill him and
not have to worry about him later mostly
because he wants to kill us and so what
happened is all three Thor's teamed up
and they killed Gor and then one of the
Thor's took the necro sword and they
threw it into a black hole and so that
was the end of him that was the end of
war a story over done and done now
within the pages of Jason Aaron's run on
Thor you had like rocks on oil which was
like this really mean company that did
mean stuff and like polluted the
atmosphere and Captain Planet would have
hated him and so what happened is while
all that was going on in the backup
pages of each story you had Thor
fighting Galactus now what happens as a
lead up to this is that in Loki agent of
Asgard issue number 12 Loki and Thor are
old they're basically old people and
Thor gets promoted to being the head of
Asgard and Loki's like well you know
what if you get to rule Asgard then I
get to rule my own kingdom and so he
takes over earth and so Thor is like
dude what are you doing man you cannot
take over Earth and he's like yes I can
not only can I take over Earth I can use
my magic to kill everybody and so that's
what he does he wipes everybody out now
this is where the story begins to shift
because everything in Jason Aaron's run
of the main Marvel Universe took place
in our normal timeline Loki killing
everybody created a new alternate
reality and that's where this battle
between Thor and Galactus takes place
thousands of years after Loki he killed
everyone and after the god butcher had
killed all the Asgardians except her I
guess all the Asgardians and all the
gods except for Thor Thor is like the
last dude left and so he's like hanging
out on earth and he's got granddaughters
don't ask me why they were there or how
they're there they're just there
whatever he's got granddaughters and
they're just like hey look pops you got
to stop hanging out you know at this
this this earth this place is dead you
know it's it's not cool anymore you know
you got it you know this this earth is
so ratchet you got to stop hanging out
here I think ratchet is a phrase to use
I don't know I'm not caught up on modern
slang but they're like this earth is so
ratchet you got to stop hanging out here
and so so Thor's like yeah I guess I
mean you know everything is pretty much
dead there's no reason for you to stay
here anymore
and then Galactus shows up and Galactus
is like let's do this [ __ ] I'm hungry
let's eat planet Earth so Thor is like
our granddaughters you got to get out of
here like go shopping here is why credit
card do whatever you want to do so he
sends a matter there
and they're off doing their shopping
thing JCPenney I guess a swore girl shop
these days I have no idea I don't know
where girls go to shop and all I
remember is that they used to go to
JCPenney mcoppins in the 1990s so uh
they are out shopping doing their thing
and Thor is like okay Galactus let's
let's let's not consume the earth this
is not okay you should not do this
because the earth is important to me and
it is my home and Galactus is like sorry
about your luck who's like people on
earth have been defying me forever the
first time I came here the Silver Surfer
turned against me and the Fantastic Four
defeated me which doesn't make any sense
whatsoever because he is Galactus and he
could have just phased the earth out of
existence or phased the Fantastic Four
and the Silver Surfer added existence
whatever 1960s Jack Kirby Stan Lee comic
book logic don't ask questions hashtag
comic logic so anyway so he's like the
second time I came here I don't number
what happened then but he's like this is
the third time I'm gonna try to consume
Earth and and it's happened in this town
because no one's gonna stand in my way
and Thor's like well I'm gonna stand in
your way
yes I'm missing an arm yes I'm blind in
one eye but I have I have have courage I
have the strength of will to to beat you
and so he's like I'm going to do hope
that I could do it and if there's hope
then maybe he won't get his get his ass
kicked which he does actually but what
is it happening is he calls down mule
near and he calls down his arm which is
part of the destroyer armor which
doesn't matter and he has the four force
now those of you guys who don't know in
Marvel Comics we have what's called the
odinforce aka a plot device the
odinforce basically allows Odin to do
whatever he needs to do at any one
particular time to solve any one
particular problem unless it comes to
fighting the Celestials in which case he
gets totally obliterated and the
Celestials are basically like get out of
my face and like they crush Odin but
what isn't happening here the his Thor
has the Thor force which is basically he
inherited the odinforce and I was called
the Thor force whatever and he uses it
against Galactus if the problem here is
that because of the lack does is like
the devourer of worlds and he's got the
power cosmic which is another plot
device so let's go back to Steve
whatever he needs to do with any
particular point in time
Thor's Thor force does not work now the
entire time he's like dude Galactus he
can't just run around and consume
people's planets man that's not okay all
right like we are Bros and Bros do not
consume other people's planets and
Galactus is like yeah but dude like this
planet has a common man like you guys
have been really arrogant
and no one cares if you're dead in fact
they'd be happy with you dead and and
you know no one cares so I'm gonna
consume the planet Plus like the
universe is dying and there's less life
and I'm hungry because there's less
planets to eat now and and I'm gonna
consume the earth net just all there is
to it and so far is like okay fine
whatever so like they're fighting each
other they're going back and forth like
Thor's won't resolve but he's holding
his own against Galactus that should not
be possible but he is able to do it and
he's holding his own and he's doing well
and then Galactus is like no any punches
Thor then punches Thor through the
planet and destroys the moon so then
Thor's like okay like this is this is
some crazy [ __ ] the guy country through
a planet this is the level stuff I need
to keep fighting but I'll see you to
come up with an idea so he is he's
fighting Galactus some more and Galactus
is like dude if you guys gotta hear a
sort of God I'm just gonna destroy it so
he like punches Thor again and Thor
flies off the planet and he's like
thousands of light-years away and so
then like his daughters come back
they're like oh hey guys we're done
shopping oh my god this right Galactus
and so like they start fighting against
Galactus and one of the daughters has
like Stormbreaker which is the hammer of
beta ray bill and then another one has
yarn Bjorn and then another one has some
mace that belongs to some guy who's like
the third cousin fourth time removed
from Thor whatever and so like they're
all fighting against Galactus and
Galactus is like dude are you guys
serious are you for real right now
because this this is nonsense like you
guys are like this is just annoying as
[ __ ]
just let me consume the earth and be on
my way that's all I want to do and so
they're just like biding their time so
Thor's like okay look like I'm just
floating out here in space right now
gilad just punched me to the far side of
the universe I need to I really need an
idea and so he ends up going back to the
black hole where he previously through
the necro sword where he'd killed gods
and he grabs a necro sword and he pulls
it out like King Arthur pulling the
sword out of the stone then he's like
alright cool let's do this so we go back
to the daughters and the daughters are
like fighting Galactus and he's still
trying to hold her and hold their own
like Galactus killed the goats so they
know that Galactus is at this point he's
just being a dick he's just like I'm
just gonna kill the ghost just just to
be just to be a jerk to you guys so like
he kills the goats and the girls are
like oh my god he killed the goats oh my
god this is crazy he killed the goats
and so like then like Thor shows back up
they're like oh my god Thor is that like
the necros war you have in your hand oh
my god it corrupts the wheels of the
people that have that and it's going to
corrupt you and he was like I don't give
a
we got his saber so he is he goes to
Galactus and like like punches gonna you
know hits Galactus with the sword and
Galactus is armor is just like shattered
and all the pieces off like that and
Galactus is like look dude I know you
distract me with a sword that I
recognize as being something really old
and it's capable of killing gods but I
am never gonna give in and Thor's like I
don't give a damn and so like he stabs
Galactus anyway and so Galactus is like
basically like it seems like he's dead
and so Thor is like bleeding all over
the place well it turns out that
apparently something that we never knew
which is really really interesting this
this is this is wild I guess it's a new
concept
whenever as Guardians bleed it makes the
earth come back to life and so like
captain Captain Planet is being reborn
you know and he was like with your blood
on my surface I am Captain Planet and so
he comes back not really but the earth
is being reborn again and stuff is like
grass and stuff is growing and so then
we find out in the epilogue that Thor
was like okay look like this man I
recognize that you're hungry you know I
get that you're starving like I'm not
that big of a dick here is the sword
hold on to it for safekeeping so nobody
else can use it and go consume ours and
so Galactus is like yeah I'm consuming
Mars man he's like what is this the
sword is inside of me and then he
becomes like the butcher of worlds and
we never find out what happens to after
that don't ask me why probably because
of secret Wars which is kind of a dumb
reason because it's not like Marvel
rebooted so the story should just keep
going Jason Aaron if you ever watch this
video please make that happen anyway
yeah so with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it I post some
like just like give me some likes give
me some comments make sure you guys
subscribe join the Rob core if this is
your first time here then yeah I will
catch you all later peace